well all Trump russia house panel
hearings have been suddenly canceled
that's weird right there are multiple
investigations into the Donald Trump
Russia scandal including the FBI
including a Senate panel a house panel
the house panel that's the House
Intelligence Committee panel is led by
Republican Devin Nunez who we now know
to be a trump chill running to the White
House to keep the subject of the
investigation Donald Trump apprised
about what was going on the committee
has suddenly canceled all of the
meetings scheduled this week as part of
the investigation some of the
Republicans are saying well it's not so
much that they're canceled but they're
delayed with no date to which they've
been rescheduled which I call canceled
this investigation has lost all
credibility at this point is quickly
falling apart Congress has got to wake
up here Devin Nunez should be testifying
before the Commission not leading the
investigation and the top Democrat on
the House Intel committee congressman
Adam Schiff as well as Democratic
leaders in the House and Senate have
called on nuñez to recuse himself also
there is a Republican was called on
nuñez to recuse himself more on that
later Nunez so far is refusing to do so
and somehow Paul Ryan is still willing
to publicly say that he's confident in
Devon Nunez his ability to carry out
this investigation this is the motto for
the basically the way that this has been
carried out so far right which is
including the Trump lies about who they
met with the really sketchy actions of
those supposedly investigating what's
going on here not evidence of guilt in
and of itself but it makes you seem
really guilty and where there's some
smoke there could be fire and where
there is so much smoke you can't even
see through it there's a good chance
something is burning and the thing is
Devin Nunez apologized to his own
committee for running to the White House
before briefing them yeah if he's
willing to admit he made a mistake and
apologized you'd think he'd be willing
to right the wrong that he made and the
only way he could possibly do that is to
recuse himself that's the only way at
this point and Republicans at this point
really have to be realizing that it's
possible that if you really do the
investigation objectively it's going to
be bad
Trump otherwise why would we be seeing
everything but a full fair and objective
investigation at this point and remember
that Devin Nunez was in the Trump
transition team the Republicans who are
defending him are saying well he wasn't
an official transition team staffer he
was like an advisor or an aide to the
transition team if those are the
semantic games you have to play to
defend Devin Nunez you've already lost
you're putting in charge of the
investigation a guy who was in some way
a trump surrogate I don't know on what
planet that makes sense and you can be
sure that if Hillary Clinton's
hypothetical administration was under
investigation for ties to just for
example Iran or something like that
these meetings and hearings will be
happening round the clock and we know it
would have been the case because it was
the case with the email scandal it was
the case with a Benghazi scandal which
of course wasn't actually a scandal but
since its Trump and the Republicans it's
no big deal Democrats are just mad they
lost and luckily this is also being
investigated by the FBI and the Senate
Intelligence Committee it's just too bad
though because these intelligence
committees used to be the last vestige
of bipartisanship independence and it
seems like we've gotten beyond that
point so yeah I'll say we have I'll say
we have and folks there are so-called
liberals providing cover here by the way
saying that Democrats should stop
focusing on this this shouldn't be a
partisan issue everyone should be
focusing on this those who are saying
that by talking about this Democrats are
in some way hurting their cause
everybody should be incredibly disturbed
by what is alleged here and I don't buy
for a second that we should even be
approaching this from a partisan lens of
course it is because everything in
Congress is partisan at this point and
one of the reasons cited for the
cancellations that I've been talking to
you about one of the reasons is proposed
as an explanation as to why Devon nuñez
has canceled the Trump Russia hearings
is to keep Sally gates from testifying
and I'm going to talk to you about that
next